قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الدافعات الجويه اعترضت جسما طائرا مشبوها
في الجليل الاعلى شمالي اسرائيل كما رصدت
جسما اخر يرجح ان يكون طائره مسيره تسللت
من جنوب لبنان وسقطت في منطقه مرجليوث في
الجليل الاعلى ما ادى لاصابه اسرائيليين
في انفجار المسيره دون الاصاح عن وضعهم
الصحي وافادت مراسله الجزيره بسماع دوي
انفجارات ناجمه عن قصف مدفعي اسرائيلي
لبلدات حدوديه
لبنانيه ياتي ذلك في اعقاب اعلان حزب الله
عن تنفيذه خمس عمليات هجمات ضد مواقع
اسرائيليه حيث هاجمه بطائره مسيره تجمعا
للجنود الاسرائيليين خارج ثكنه رميم كما
استهدف الحزب جنودا اسرائيليين في المناره
والمطل وفي موقع بركت ريشا وقوه مشاه في
محيط الموقع
ذاته من مرجعيون جنوبيه لبنان ينضم الينا
مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي ومن الجليل
الاعلى تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره فاطمه
خمايسي مرحبا بكما وابدا معك ايهاب
التفاصيل المتعلقه بهذه المسيرات التي
اطلقت من
لبنان طبعا حزب الله اليوم اعلن بشكل واضح
انه اطلق سيره انقضاض على ثكنه رميم ثكنه
رميم تقع قباله بلده مركبه في القطاع
الاوسط وقال حزب الله انه حقق اصابات في
هذا الهجوم الذي شنه بهذه المسيره
الدفاعات الجويه الاسرائيليه كانت اطلقت
عددا من الصواريخ في القطاع الاوسط ايضا
في محاوله لاعتراض بعض الاهداف الجويه
التي لم يعلن عن طبيعتها عن طبيعتها حزب
الله لكن الحزب حاول منذ صباح هذا اليوم
استهداف الجنود الاسرائيليين والحاق خسائر
بالارواح في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ
الساعه السابعه صباحا هاجم ثكنه بركه ريشا
ودمر دشمه يتحصن فيها الجنود الاسرائيليون
ثم عاجل الموقع نفسه بعد ساعه اثر تحرك
للجنود هناك وهاجمه ايضا بالاسلحه
الصاروخيه وحقق اصابات ا ثكنه المنار او
تحديدا مستوطنه المناره الواقعه قباله
بلده ميس الجبل في القطاع الاوسط شن عليها
حزب الله هجوما صاروخيا ادى الى تدمير
منزلين يتحصن بهما الجيش الاسرائيلي وكل
كل عمليا المستوطنات والمنازل المتاخمه
للحدود تحولت الى ثكنات عسكريه تدريجيا
ابتداء من الثامن من اكتوبر تاريخ بدء
العمليات التي شنها حزب الله على الجانب
الاسرائيلي ايضا منطقه المطلي استهدفت
وكذلك قصف الجيش الاسرائيلي بالطائرات
الحربيه سلسله غارات ونفذ سلسله غارات نعم
في القطاع الغربي وقصفت المدفعيه اماكن
مختلفه من جنوب لبنان وفاطمه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتحدث اذا عن اعتراض هذه
المسيرات بدفاعات
جويه في البدايه زميلي محمد يعني اسمح لي
ان اتقدم باحر التعازي لعائله الزميل
الشهيد سامر ابو دقه في غزه وايضا في
بلجيكا يعني تعازينا الحاره لعائلته وايضا
لسائر الزملاء في اسره الجزيره وبالحديث
يعني عن الجبهه الشماليه اذا ما اردنا ان
نرصد اخر التطورات والوضع الميداني الحالي
نستطيع القول بان سفارات الانذار قد دوت
في الساعات الاخيره عده مرات في مواقع
مختلفه في الجليل الغربي وايضا في الجليل
الاعلى ونتحدث عن اعتراض الدفاعات الجويه
لمسيره لبنانيه اطلقت من جنوب لبنان
باتجاه موقع اسرائيلي وايضا كان هنالك
مسيره اخرى لم تنجح الدفاعات الجويه
باعتراضه من مما ادى الى انفجارها بالقرب
من بلده مارلوت الاسرائيليه الحدوديه
ووسائل الاعلام تحدثت عن اصابه اسرائيليين
بجروح ولكنها لم تفصل ولم توضح ماهيه هذه
الاصابات وايضا لم تفصح اذا كانت هذه
الاصابات في صفوف المدنيين الاسرائيليين
ام الجنود وعلى ما يبدو ان الرقابه
العسكريه تفرض حذر نشر جدا كبير على هذا
الحدث بشكل خاص طبعا الجيش الاسرائيلي
ايضا لم يت تطرق الى موضوع الاصابات في
بيانه الاخير وقال ان الدفاعات الجويه ق
قد قامت باعتراض مسيره واخرى انفجرت فيما
قام بمواصله قصف المواقع اللبنانيه
المتفرقه في الحدود وقال انه يستهدف بنى
عسكريه ومواقع لاطلاق الصواريخ تابع لحزب
الله